[Music]  it was a big night for country music on  TV last week on Nashville we said  goodbye to Rayna James  this week we saw rayna's family mourn  her loss at an extremely emotional  funeral how thoughts in love will last  forever  the episode soft familiar faces returned  to pay their respects including Reina  sister Tandy and her incarcerated  ex-husband Teddy but perhaps most  touching Raina's daughter Maddie  performing a tribute at the CMT Awards  thank you  over on the voice Adam Levine had a near  meltdown over country artist Cassie joy  who he assumed would pick coach Blake  Shelton  I have been beaten down so many times by  hearing a voice like yours which clearly  is rooted in that traditional country  thing so I'm not gonna get my hopes up  Adam even left his chair to walk  offstage and sulk I just need to be left  alone right now  ultimately it was a tough choice but  Cassie kept it country with Blake  you